hey i'm kevin hey i'm kira i'm jeff and
today we're going to be drawing a
stranger based
only on their voice and self-description
are you guys excited i'm so excited
this is going to get weird it's going to
get very weird
you know what i'm here for it
[Music]
so please welcome our guests for today
their name is
ishmael
ishmael you have a great voice what is
that accent um mississippi
southern whatever vicksburg like you
call it or
some of my people know it as the city
best city in the state of mississippi
maybe
the entire united states so ishmael
how did you comfy on the show watch the
original episode
then i waited for the post on instagram
when i posted it i thought
oh there's no way they're going to
choose me and here i go
dreams come true dreams come true
right so here's how it works ishmael
can't see our screens
we can't see each other's screens so the
only way we know what to draw
is by what ishmael tells us and if
you're playing along at home be sure to
post your drawing and tag us
on instagram and twitter at drawoffshow
all right everybody ready yes i guess so
okay so first things first ishmael can
you please tell
us your pronouns and your ethnicity him
indian african american
okay what kind of head shape
would you describe yourself having they
go with rectangle
rectangle with a circle inside fuller in
the face especially in your voice you
have a lot of like
laughter and energy and stuff so i can
imagine like fuller cheeks and stuff
like that yes
most definitely what would you say your
hair is similar to
is it like really like big
or is it like pretty close to your head
like pretty shaved or so
it's close to my head and as we use it's
i would say wavy like the ocean
but i'm probably lying to myself so
ripples like the ocean but
i think that's enough to get us started
so in the meantime ishmael tell us
tell us about yourself uh born and
raised in mississippi
i guess you could say i usually call
myself young ishmael at what age are you
no longer allowed to say that you're a
youngish man because
i need to know that as well
i would personally say the age someone
finally calls you out on it multiple
times not just
[Music]
all right well there's no hope for me
then
so ishmael what do you do for a living i
work at the local community college
highest community college
financial aid i love it i love it
different experience every day
but i actually love it uh let me do
something i love which is interact with
people and
help people so financially what i do for
a living what is a celebrity that you
think that you look like
that you feel like you could do an
impression of first one comes to mind is
chris rock because of the office where
michael scott did his impression
chris rock that one the other one uh
maybe a little bit niche
but do they heal from uh from west wing
no from like i know from also from west
wing
i always find myself doing his jamaican
accent um
one tone london town then inside the
curse word
shaw you must wash your mind
i think i could do a fairly decent maybe
decent
newbie or strong nice to meet you i
smell
that's really good that's really good
there's a little grover in there too
what kind of like clothes do you like
wearing you
like wearing like bright colored you
know like tank tops or like you like
long shirts never wear jeans uh never
wear a t-shirt really
um i like to describe it as coach's
attire
um you know it looks like i'm about to
get ready to go coach a ball with me
every day of the week actually i modeled
myself after
jim trelso to be honest if some
professional sports team or whatever
doesn't have that color scheme i'm not
throwing it on
are you a big sports guy yes most
definitely uh
um i i don't like the oh i do love to
say it but i usually don't like saying
my teams too much because
uh it's a lot of a lot of tears i
learned how to cry through sports uh
because we're often losing in the most
heartbreaking fashion it's it's hard
jessica how how are you doing on your
drawings
good i made you look like way younger i
think than you actually are
i think i'm doing pretty good this feels
this feels good
all right i'm like 65 confident in mine
very important question bottom half of
the face how much fuzz are we talking
solid one
not james harden um okay but not smooth
okay just i'm able to run the cone
through it
um but if you look real close at the
chin
you can run a comb through it yeah i'm
gonna come through it
this changes everything
it's okay it's okay that's great that's
okay okay
yeah you're gonna see three artists very
quickly try to
reconfigure their drawings
oh i don't even know how to do this i
know see
okay so for eyebrows would you say your
eyebrows are like
on the thicker side or how would you
describe them at one point time people
look i'm like
oh you go and get your eyebrows done i'm
like no
i don't they're pretty bushy to me oh
boy
i feel like we've gotten a lot of
information in the last
like you know 30 seconds that have like
completely
gone against what i've been drawing this
entire time
it's always the way though i added some
facial hair
and you know what i don't like it
so i'm gonna i'm gonna turn off those
layers and
i'm gonna you know what i'm strong and
wrong this is
this is not gonna look like you if i i'm
gonna tell you right now
it's not gonna be it all right pens down
how do we think we did
let me tell you ishmael but you've got a
lot of character in your voice
ishmael you're an enigma of a man
we hope that you don't get offended by
our drawings oh
i feel confident
[Music]
that i got that i got the
the spirit the spirit in there
that's what i that's what i feel really
good about okay you know we're supposed
to be drawing likenesses though
yes all right well let's send them to
each other
and smile as well
[Music]
wow you guys are so good
these little shirts oh my gosh
just damn it
once again yes showing everyone up oh
dang no everybody got like what i would
consider the most important feature
the smile like everybody got
like as i like to call it open mouth
smile
right now the comic book for jess is
like one of those anime characters
i wanted to be for kevin's it'd
definitely be like a cartoon
type sitcom type ordeal and uh
kyra ceases to fail to make everything
look cute no matter
especially with the way that ishmael
talks how he sounds it very much feels
like somebody that's really
excited about the future like willing to
learn
experiencing new things so i wanted to
make sure to really capture that and for
me he said dule hill
and so i just drew dooley hill
sorry i just i panicked
all right ishmael it is time for the big
reveal and if you are drawing along at
home be sure to pause here and finish
your drawing
because we're about to see what ishmael
really looks like
whenever you're ready ishmael three
two
wow you are like a fusion between kevin
and
justice draw
this is great your facial hair is way
longer than any of us thought it was
i didn't get to comb through it yet oh
man you can do some viking braids
well ishmael thank you very much for
being our guest today
we had a lot of fun drawing you oh thank
you most definitely thank you guys i
truly truly really appreciate it
i like my day honestly i relate to my
day for a better look at these drawings
your drawings and to find out how you
could be one of our next strangers
be sure to follow us on instagram and
twitter at drop show
and we'll see you next time when you
want to see this pretty little face
animated wouldn't you want to see this
face
drawn in the styles of the amazing
artist on draw
[Music]